[Spoiler Warning]
This is one of the most violent and ruthless
pirates in all of One Piece.
A man, who took out one of the four emperors
and exchanged blows with two more.
This is someone who after two years in the
New World, has lost an arm but gained enormous
power in return.
While Luffy is going to face the mysterious
and destructive powers of Blackbeard as his
biggest fight in the story yet, HE is bound
to take down his foil.
Shanks.
And, according to Eiichiro Oda himself, the
true reason that Kid wants to take down shanks
is not related to losing his arm.
Equipped with the frightening combination
of both, a devastating and fully awakened
devil fruit AND the will of a conqueror, he
doesn't show mercy to his enemies, like these
ones who he had crucified and disposed of,
as he is willing to do literally anything,
even the most unthinkable things to get a
step closer to his ultimate goal.
The throne of the pirate world.
But then there is also this.
The worries and love for a Nakama.
Growing closer and fighting side by side with
Luffy.
Until we actually see him cheering for Luffy
and trusting in his power.
How do these two radically different traits
come together in the same person.
Who is this man, that shares so many similarity
with the most mysterious and powerful characters
in One PIece.
His red hair, his missing arm, the scars over
his eyes.
And what is his actual purpose as Luffy's
arguably most evil ally in the story?
This gruesome depiction here is an illustration
of something that really happened.
Because Captain Eustass Kid and his character
are inspired by the real life pirates Eustass
the monk and Captain William Kid.
The was latter was infamous for his cruelty.
William Kid was the son of another famous
pirate, Captain John Kidd.
And who knew, THIS elderly gentleman with
a very unhealthy complexion is actually the
infamous captain John, former member of the
Rocks pirates and revived by Gecko Moria.
And even though Kid looks a lot more like
another certain red head, it has been speculated
that this guy right here might be a much more
likely candidate for Kid's father...that he
never had.
This also shows in his devil fruit powers.
While Luffy is creative, flexible and funny,
like his rubbery sun god devil fruit, Kid's
cold, iron-hard and edgy nature is wonderfully
embodied in his Jiki Jiki fruit, that not
only looks absolutely fire, but is also ridiculously
powerful.
Sadly we didn't get to see much of Kid's fighting
before Onigashima, especially this moment
here, where he was ambushed by Kaido..god
I wish I'd get to see that.
These panels during Onigashima however, DO
show us how his fruit truly works in its pure
and awakened form.
And so I feel like Eiichiro Oda, the Oda of
One PIece has made up for this.
This here for example is Punk Clash, one of
Kid's strongest abilities, turning Big Mom
into such a strong magnet, that even giant
steel-beams from the castle's wall crushed
into her.
While in his base form, Kid himself is magnetic,
his awakening allows him to assign magnetism
to areas and objects that he touches.
An extremely overpowered ability, as I think
Big Mom's defeat at Kid's and Law's hands
more than clearly proves.
I think when Eustass Kid introduces himself
to us for the very first time in the story,
overseeing the terrible human action on Sabaody,
he also gives us the most important piece
of information about himself.
As he watches nobles and other people with
money and influence enter the auction house
to buy people like property, he tells us exactly
what he thinks about this all.
'World Nobles...
Slaves...
Human shops...
Against the "purity" of these so-called nobles,
the villains of the world look positively
humane in comparison.
It's because the world's in the hands of scum
like them that it's all broken...
I mean, we're not the nicest of guys, but
at least we're honest about it.'
Kid is very much aware that he is not exactly
on the jolly side of piracy like Luffy is.
He knows very well that the things he does
are terrible.
However if he sees himself down here on the
moral ladder, the people who rule this world
are not only 5 levels below him, but also
responsible for people like him to become
this twisted and cruel in the first place.
And I believe, this is also how we tend to
see kid as well.
A much darker version of Luffy, who is willing
to do messed-up things, extremely messed up
things.
But at the same time, it seems pretty clear
that he also is fighting for a world without
the government or at least a world where he
can be free from them, just like Luffy.
And that's exactly the main point of his character.
What I find beyond interesting, is that Eustass
Kid doesn't only play the contrasting character
for one, but TWO people in the story.
This is Kid's giant magnetic arm next to Luffy's
gear third.
Here are Luffy and Kid having a competition
about literally anything in Udon prison.
Who can carry the most.
Who can eat the most.
Who can make Queens eyes bulge the most.
And this is Kid, just like Luffy, beaten by
Kaido in a cell, but refusing to give up.
They hate nothing more than losing.
Both on Sabaody and on Wano, we see Luffy
and Kidd storming on ahead, witch Law trying
to reign them in and protect their backs form
any threat.
And not for nothing has Kid always been portrayed
as the straw hat's number one rival amongst
the supernova for becoming king of the pirates.
But what’s the deal with him and shanks?
Ohh, i left you on a cliff hanger there on
purpose, because first we need to talk about
the delicious sponsor of today’s video.
Bokksu.
Bokksu is a monthly snack box subscription
service that delivers original assortments
of premium Japanese snacks and tea pairings,
directly from Japan to wherever you may live.
Every box has a unique theme, and so this
month Bokksu is celebrating its 6th anniversary
with the bokksu tanjoubi box, which if you
are nihongo jouzu literally means the bokksu
birthday box.
The best thing about this, besides how good
all this stuff tastes, is that they collaborate
with traditional Japanese family manufacturers
that make these snacks and candies.
I have my eyes particularly on the strawberry
truffels mochi from Nigata prefecture and
green tea chocolate coated azuki beans from
Yamagata.
So, this is the perfect opportunity to experience
some great authentic Japanese food.
If you want to try it out for yourself, go
get your own Bokksu snack box and get $15
off your first order using my code Ohara 15
& the link in the description below!
A very popular saying you might have come
across somewhere before is that Kidd is Luffy
without the plot armour.
And even though I don't really like that term,
because plot armour is just plot, I agree
with the idea behind this.
On the plus side, Kid is Luffy but not bound
to the classic moral standards of a Shounen
hero.
He loves his crew like Luffy, but towards
anyone else he is just straight out cruel.
And he can use any means possible to get stronger
and achieve his dream, without Oda-sensei
having to worry about the message to his audience.
On the down side however, not being Luffy
means that Kid also doesn't share his ability
to create allies that help him become stronger.
Instead of being trained by Reighleigh for
2 years, he directly marches into the New
world, where he almost loses his life to Shanks.
Oh yeah Shanks.
Missing arm, scar over the eye, red hair.
No coincidence, because this is the second
character that Kidd is a foil to.
Think about it: Shanks sacrificed an arm to
inspire Luffy to become a pirate, while taking
an arm from Kid, who for some mysterious reason
is obsessed with him.
While Shanks doesn't mind having one arm,
Kid feels the need to replace his with his
devil fruit power, though I honestly do fully
understand that.
The main point of comparison between this
YOnko and this supernova however, is how they
deal with people who laugh at them.
As you well know, in chapter one, just after
Luffy ate his mythical Zoan devil fruit, Shanks
calmly takes a beating by Higuma and his mountain
bandits.
Something that Luffy imitates on Jaya with
Bellamy.
If you're curious why that was such a big
deal, I made a whole video about that scene
with Bellamy and Blackbeard.
The point is, Kidd behaves, well just like
a kid, just like kid Luffy, he punishes and
kills those who dare to laugh at his dreams,
while Luffy and Shanks pity those without
a dream and don't see them as worthy opponents.
In other words, Kid quite literally to his
name, needs to grow up.
Which, as we will see in a second, he has
been doing during the wano arc.
Now, I recently bought the 14th volume of
the official One PIece magazine, fittingly
enough titled rivals by the way, that had
a massive character discussion section about
Kid, that helped me a lot with this analysis.
Finally all that Japanese study is coming
in handy.
The main theme of Kid and his crew is literally
that of rebels, of being anti-establishment.
While Kid obviously has a strong steam-punk-heavy
metal theme going on himself with, just look
at this attack and those goggles.
And I mean the ship is just awesome, by far
my favorite design in the entire story.
It's called the victoria punk and has this
giant skull as its bow.
And funnily enough, apart from kid and his
childhood friend Killer, the name of every
of his crew members is based on famous rock
bands or other music terms.
Heat, who can literally breathe fire, is based
on this Swedish band.
This is wire, named after the English rock
band.
There are also house, boogie and my two favorite
Nakama hip and hop, who I think have the most
most awesome and most lazy names in all of
One Piece at the same time.
The second and much more hidden theme in the
crew is something I would have never guessed
though honestly.
The kid pirates are also hippies.
Look at this:
killers pants or heat's outfit.
You can't unsee it once you know.
And to me it really nicely reflects these
two sides of kid himself, the rough and edgy
together with this sort-of kind, fun and peaceful
side of him.
A fun little story I discovered in the magazine
as well, is that Kid and killer are not only
best childhood friends form the south blue,
but they also had the same childhood crush,
that spilled a bowl of Udon over herself,
which is why it now is both of their least
favorite foods, which is a hilarious little
pun Oda-sensei has made, because both Kid
and Killer were held captive in Udon Prison.
But I also think that it once again hints
at Kid's kinder and more caring side.
I kind of side-tracked there for a second,
but I'm convinced that we got all of these
little details, because they help illustrate
who Kid truly is as a character.
Kid clearly has suffered through a lot of
trauma and pain throughout his life.
This is him as a kid, clearly growing up in
a harsh environment.
According to Oda-sensei, Kid's most important
principal in life is having no concern for
anyone but his Nakama.
In other words for those he trusts, Kid would
do anything, something he proves to us with
his reaction when he finds out that Killer
had been forced to eat a smile devil fruit.
Clearly it is really hard for Kid to build
trust with others.
Which really hits home the one time we see
him grudgingly forming an alliance with Apoo
and Hawkins, only to be betrayed right away.
So when you look at this Kid at the beginning
of wano, angry and distrusting vs this kid
right here, thrilled with the joy of battle
and trusting in Luffy to take down Kaido 1
vs 1, damn girl, what a glow-up.
He only joins the raid because he wants revenge
on Kaido in the first place, kind-of tagging
along, while still doing his own thing.
Like 'I'm not part of your alliance, but I
guess you will lose without me, so I'll come'.
Strong Tsundere vibes from Kid here.
I think spending time with Luffy in Udon definitely
was the basis for him even tagging along in
the first place.
But he is the one who will take down Kaido.
THIS here however is the first change of character
however, as he sees Zoro heroically risking
his own life for everyone else on the roof.
That's not something a traitor would do.
Over the course of the fight, Kid sees the
true nature of Luffy, Zoro and Law and while
he keeps arguing with them, he more and more
integrates as part of the team.
He counts on Law to have his back and starts
coordinating his attacks with him and Luffy.
Finally, when Big Mom reappears, he focuses
on separating the two yonko's now fully believing
in Luffy and acknowledging his powers.
I think it's more than likely that Kid might
accompany Luffy to THIS island, where Shanks
is waiting and confront him there.
Because, Elbaf has been been foreshadowed
as the next major arc in the story.
And so if you want to know all the crazy events
that might await Kid and Luffy on the island
of the giants, you really should watch this
video here next and see what the story has
in store for them.
I really hope you enjoyed this video, and
I see you in the next one.